[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as US chess champs calm
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 summer chess classic as always your
your hosts my name is Caleb Denby I'm
joined with the wonderful Grandmaster
Jessie cry for commentary here today
today is round nine the penultimate
round of the summer chess classic the
standings are still closed at the top so
anything could happen but the clock is
running out for those players trying to
catch the lead and get that number one
place why don't we just see where we
stand in the standings in Group A we
have a two-way tie for the lead with
liam Lee and David Howell Jeffrey Jong
has fallen a half point behind after a
rough round six I believe and Sam
chenkin also his fault as a half point
behind with an even score of four out of
eight go Ian Jones and daro spirits both
a trail by a full point with three and a
half out of eight and over in Group B we
have Gregorio Oprah and up at the top
leading by a full point and so today is
going to be like the last day that Sam
Sabean has a chance to catch Oprah if
Sam doesn't get it done today with a win
there's almost no chance he can catch
Oprah in Alana's caboose ian is also
trying to catch up but with only an even
score after the first eight rounds it's
looking like he cannot actually catch
that first place position unless you
know barring a miracle following him or
Surya Ganguly Igor Kovalenko and Daniel
Friedman and over in Group C it's it's
also the story of one man our tears and
Ike songs also leading by a full point
going into this penultimate round today
is a big day because he's playing
Dimitri Gordy and Grady have ski who was
the number two player so that game is
really going to decide the standings in
Group C let's take a look at the
tournament format
and so there are three groups of six
players playing doublet round-robin and
the tournament format is actually a
pretty tricky one today I think some of
the players were a little bit confused
about the pairings so I'll definitely
have to talk about that when we see some
of the games the time control for these
games is 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and once they hit move 40 they get
30 minutes added on for the remainder of
the game they get a 30 second increments
starting from move one there's also a 30
move draw rule in effect so no drawers
before move 30 let's take a look at the
schedule for this event so here we are
round 9 all the way down on Thursday so
today our show started at 3:30 p.m. but
you can see here on the schedule that
tomorrow the round actually starts two
hours earlier so we're planning to start
our show at 1:30 but if the Croatia
broadcast happens to run long we will
start a half hour after that broadcast
ends as always you can join us here on
YouTube or keep an eye and eye on the
chat we see you guys in there
Silvia Villa and Tom Tom as well as
supernova good to have you talking with
us in the YouTube chat you can also join
us on us chess champs calm where you can
follow all of the games live and if you
want to follow us on Twitter you're
welcome to do that
at st. Louis chess club and use the
hashtag summer chess classic to get
involved well Jesse what do you think of
the games today what do you think of the
parents any exciting things to look out
for
well definitely Group a everything can
still happen and we're going to look at
those games first and the other when we
get to the big difference is these
people are really close I think
technically anyone can still win it yeah
in Group A and Group B and C we're gonna
see there's a case of severe leader at
the top right so let's take a look at
these pairings in Group A we have Dara's
routes playing in Sam Shanklin Liam Lee
one of the tournament co-leaders is
paired against Joanne Jones and David
Howell against Jeffrey Zhang is our key
matchup for the day David Howe leading
the tournament and Jeffrey hoping to
catch up just a half point behind so
this is definitely going to decide a lot
we see the players there and Jeffrey
actually has a
huge time advantage up over 30 minutes
over David Howell and it looks like he
has a nice position as well what do you
think of this game yeah this was a
curious situation you know first of all
it's it's very typical that Howe has a
huge time and disadvantage from the
beginning and one funny thing you know I
got to hang out a little bit with Gawain
Jones last night and he was saying cuz I
cuz I asked him I was like is it that he
doesn't he's just started sinking in the
opening or what's going on and what he
seemed to say was that actually what's
going on is he's like really trying to
remember everything before he plays and
move which is strange in itself but I
know several other top players do it in
this game he kind of got caught
immediately with a move I'm pretty sure
it was at least unfamiliar with with 97
he looks pretty strange offhand and
let's just say the natural response here
would be d4 but anyways he starts taking
here he's third thinking here and what
he did was fine you know and we get this
position which is novel and strange and
so one thing maybe Jeffery even had in
mind here was just to play reasonable
moves but ones that were just unfamiliar
and you know whether you have howls time
pressure problem or not if you get a
novel position around move five or six
in my experience always goes to time
pressure that's just the nature of the
beast I do want to mention I got a
chance to talk to Mike comer who's the
arbiter for this event and he told me
that a David Hale actually ran into some
unexpected problems today so because of
this double round-robin format in order
to avoid one player having the same
color like three times in a row you do
have to switch around a couple of the
pairings from the first half to the
second half and so David Hale was
actually expecting to play going Jones
this countryman today with the black
pieces but to his surprise he was paired
against Jeffery with white so while
Jeffery already hit him with that novel
kind of 97 moves
operation probably wouldn't have made
too much of a difference I'm sure it was
kind of an unexpected shock to be
playing a totally different opponent
than who you thought at the beginning of
the day right you know but think about
it this way so what does he do he says
all right I'll play Knight f3 and g3 and
then just see what happens right well
right away we're getting a novel
position with 97 anything could have
happened after that yeah of course
but I think maybe he was a little bit
upset but this maybe I'm more fragile
than these players like anything like
that would kind of throw me off a little
bit psychologically even if it doesn't
necessarily make a difference with the
preparation yeah so you know we're gonna
see that that that I think here how well
has a nice position but things get
strange soon and Knight c3 maybe you
shouldn't do it maybe you should just
play Bishop g2 because now it's gonna
get forcing with Knight b6 Knight f5 and
you really don't want to play III it's
probably playable anyways this is how it
goes
snip and then castles and that's this is
the kind of continuation you're only
gonna do as Whitis is if you've thought
forever right that's exactly what I will
did and 97 happened and all this
happened and then all of a sudden the
the dark square Bishop is a little funny
and the King on c1 it's also a little
funny where eventually a rook is gonna
land on c8 and the King is just going to
be awkward so already this development
looked like okay maybe blacks better but
here was the next move it was played and
Geoffrey's thinking about it I don't
understand this move might be five
because well for several reasons I don't
I don't understand what white wants
after rook c8 and even if I just Castle
I being black just Castle what is the
intention
of night be fine so yeah I don't get it
it's a little tough to the cipher yet
because imagine let's say I don't know
rook c8 if you do the natural king b1 I
mean that's it's just not something you
wanted was this thing to land with
definitely not oh maybe he's trying to
keep that epon from moving somehow but I
don't think that's something black
really wanted right how do you keep
those by hanging that d6 squared
yeah I don't think he wanted that deed
fun I don't know so Geoffrey's thinking
about it and how it looks to be in a
little trouble and so this would
completely upend the standings if how
we'll lost but what he's seen before
it's more tricky and we now get to see
his intention rook c8 was played and
then Knight a seven was like hmm Wow
already this looks pretty pretty crazy
after something like 93 and Knight takes
f2 I really have no idea how those
tactics work out and let's just say it's
an implicit draw offer yeah of course
because we can do this kind of thing no
is there more now the good news for
black is if he decides this is all
something he doesn't want a part of he
can play rook a8 and then castle cuz
that was another op she gets that second
change so of course Geoffrey is gonna be
looking at all kinds of things here wow
I got a question what wait isn't this I
don't understand this it's almost like I
feel like we have the wrong position
because it looks so crushing what about
this
yeah Knight be 393 was my original but
it was what's that take that looks like
nearly checkmate you have to do you have
to play Rick Dees I guess I got to do
rip t3 this is just losing well okay
take take a moment though that knight on
a white does have two pieces under
attack okay but come on it's just losing
well I'm just saying this is what he's
thinking about right now so well it
takes a lot to go for this with five
minutes on your clock well you're
already busily desperation desperation
and so there's
III like you said there's 93 rookie a
mini moves I let's just look yeah let's
take a closer look at this because this
if this is working then there's nothing
else to really consider so you have to
solve the problem of your rook and your
night
my first instinct would be to play
something like rook a8 just attacking
the knight okay gaining time than I do
this method Knight d5 I'll just play
Knight c5 now like BC 5 that is okay yes
I I didn't fully appreciate this one
King d8 I still don't know what's
happening but know what you not what I
wanted so that's what I'm at and this is
our key position mm-hmm what of our key
position
there's just so many choices for black
that it it seems a little little
actually it's an interesting thing that
we witnessed earlier today where Bobby
was playing Nebo and he had a physician
work it's interesting psychologically
because he had several good choices and
it was actually a problem that he had so
many choices he had just had one he
would have found it the good news for
Jeffrey in this case he does have half
an hour left to David's five minutes so
there's a little bit of still it's not
that the choices might not be as friend
unless they're something absolutely
crushing here and how it's kind of it's
it's provocative to do this because
you're giving like so many things let's
look at your 93 mmm I'm gonna say that's
force maybe King d2 but let's just
pretend and you can be one looks more
more natural and then I see eight I
guess I have my choice of rooks maybe I
want to take the one on d1 so that your
Bishop on g2 stays undefended
if nothing else this looks like a pawn
to the good right yeah but even if I do
this if I was Jeffrey this is precisely
the kind of thing I'd be like is that
really all I got because now at the bare
minimum white can do that and that yeah
that's that's fair enough to say but and
there might not so anything else that's
just me lazily taking back on the one
there might be some 96 I have no idea I
it's hard to imagine anything but black
being at least a little bit better here
right I mean there's has to be an
advantage of some kind no matter what
line Jeffery goes down you would think
that look at the father gave today there
was he was oh he was had the advantage
in every single line and then he
actually as a chess fan as a Fabi fan
I'm traumatized but what happened today
actually aim to watch very similar to
this position because there's so many
moves that Geoffrey can play here well I
get the feeling Geoffrey's gonna be
thinking a while so why don't we take a
look at the B group and see what the
pairings look like we have a whole
honest kuboos Ian paired against Daniel
Freedman and that was actually quite an
interesting game today
Igor Kovalenko is paired against Sam
Sabean who is trying to chase the
tournament leader your goryeo Pirin who
was paired against Sura Ganguly in our
key matchup of the day with a win today
I believe Grigory would clinch the B
group no matter what and so let's check
on his position we see the players
they're a little bit more even on the
clocks than the first game we had to
look at but definitely a complicated
position yes and I think you know it was
funny we haven't had Oprah in the studio
yet and it's because chess fans around
the world are prejudiced towards wild
games Oberon has been playing a very
consistent old Soviet style chess which
has served him well I don't know that
applies to this game though it looks
like he's on the attack well but what I
mean is every opening he's played very
solidly and this too he just played very
convinced
simple chess and nothing fancy and it's
white who you know is pushing it pushing
his luck all right let's say bye I think
black is already at least fine in this
position right it's tough to say
anything else
f3 g5 and I don't know to my mind I
don't know if I would say black is
better but definitely more pleasant to
play with black because you're the one
who's going to be able to do things
you're gonna you're gonna make white
wonder about the G fours in this world
you know so rook f1 we do a little dance
there's multiple moves here like rook g7
could have been played he goes Queen g6
and White says to himself well I have to
do something on the green side right we
do our little doubling rook f6 and it's
very difficult for white to play this
position mg1 just fundamentally feels
like oh I didn't really want to do that
a lot
but he's protecting his rook on f1 a
little tough to find the right setup for
right here King h8 h 3 h 5 queen f 2 and
i think i think black is playing without
risk and yeah and he obviously is gonna
put this thing away right now if if he
finds the knockout and what bummer is he
can't the whites not doing anything yeah
it looks like he's just got to be
careful not to get just like beaned by
black here that's coming through a g4
and black can also take his time to do a
maneuver like move the Queen play Knight
G 695 Knight f4 that's something else
that white has to look forward to the
dark squares are very weak with this
structure of f3 and h3 both played it's
it's not pleasant yeah so many nice
moves for black and so right as we said
this would clinch the victory and
yeah would be a fantastic achievement
for Oprah and send him to it maybe then
not only the next level but maybe the
eighth tournament and yeah I'm point in
the near future might jump up a group
and even with a draw today Gregoria has
excellent chances to maintain his lead
to to win this event right and we're
gonna look later at Sam sevens game and
I guess he's the other one who might
have a chance to catch you yes I think
well let's actually take a look and see
how the C group is doing don't want to
neglect them the pairings for today are
Iran poco bein paired against the count
Christian sure illa-allah Shawn Marathi
Abadi is paired against boy genius
Brandon Jacobson but the game that has
our interest today is between archers
nights ons and Dmitry Gordievsky of
course number one and number two in the
C group so Dmitry definitely needs to
get it done today if he wants to catch
archers and have a chance to win this
event and so what has he done to advance
that goal from the beginning he's been
playing to light up the board yeah
the board is officially now lit up okay
mission accomplished
so honestly I just look you know I
looked at this maybe two minutes ago and
it really has exploded in the last
little bit why don't we walk through
this one just just to see how he got
some well worth the thing so all that's
transpired I call this the classical set
up against the perc and c6 is a little
bit more usual at 96 definitely unusual
and I would say the old
I wouldn't want to call it normal but
five would be I think some kind of
advantage for one though t5i I have a
question actually I've seen a lot of
players play just 98 they're rerouting
but I've also seen occasionally 95 right
what's happening in a structure like
that you know I think if you want to do
d5 in night be eight which maybe he
would have done anyway then it's
questionable how effective a six was
right
ie you could have played knight c6 now
yeah in fact else Sean played this
against me in a game once and yes you
can heat we did this dance and you know
you can argue that the pawn on d5 isn't
well placed and I just opened you up
yeah but of course you lost some time so
that's the you know the give and take
there always the trade-off and maybe I
don't know it's an interesting question
here and one way they'll talk to our
tours about it is our tour says you know
what I don't want to do it and in
general you know they're one of the
reasons you play d5 is you don't want
black to play e5 himself but here it
doesn't happen and Gordievsky plays d6
and so it's almost like it's a little
psychological but also like a game plan
where he wants the game to go long he
wants it to be complicated and what I
see here is someone who is striving
toward a hippo ya know definitely have
some similarities what do you think no I
say do you think arteries might have
just played D takes e5 and hoping for
some trades along the D file I mean I
know if I'm in our tour spots it's gonna
be hard to avoid the temptation to go
for something that looks equal and
drawing and just secure as my victory in
this event but you know or maybe it's
that the fear of that that led Dmitri to
actually play e6 instead of the more
naturally excited the more I see to meet
you though this is his style he likes he
likes unconventional wild positions
again one thing that's interesting about
him that is shown in this choice of
opening is he's not afraid of being
worse like he said that when in our
interview when we were talking about the
Khan open he said I don't care if I'm
you know the computer says that mine is
one I don't care so we got this position
and I thought White was had a very
pleasant edge and
I thought white had done everything
correct here okay it's so obviously a
forward now it's gonna open but I still
thought everything was great I thought
f5 very controversial how can that be
wrong 94 maybe not like a three seems
like it's also a good move but okay
let's look 894 snip now this is maybe
this is something you just overlooked I
feel like if you're gonna do Knight c4
so the problem is when Gordievsky takes
on f3 if you take with the Queen you
lose exchange but honestly you know my
guess that one out yes act the exchange
definitely I don't but though you do not
play Knight c4 if your intention is to
do that that's not what we wanted at all
so for example you could play not say a
three yeah over and they're moving
moving that night c2 trick so you always
have a little freedom of mobility and I
just want to say why it's better here
there's no big attack yeah this is a
play stuff like f4 that you still have
to worry about but I I have to agree
with you here at Pleasant edge for White
Knight a5 is something that black is
gonna have to worry about with that
Knight coming into c6 someday but so
this was an interesting moment that's
taking on f3 yeah you think that oh my
goodness Knight d5 and then he says ok
I'll give it to you and so the argument
has to be something like I gave my pawn
back but I got your light squares it's
hard to believe the g5 this is really
this is a really bad sign if you got to
play Bishop d2 and now I'm just gonna go
ahead and say black least what unless
White has something amazing here bloom
White has just lost definitely got to
prefer the black pieces but it looks
just toast
it's it happened so fast
it happened so fast and yeah we have one
late for our tours you were doing great
and you were playing a great okay
it was 97 and let's see one I believe
there we go Wow look see one there we go
yeah there's many pleasant opportunities
here for for black wasn't five for
example where's this night on e7 heading
we just didn't want to exchange yeah
okay okay so if Bishop c5 looks natural
this would totally this changes
everything
yeah this this is going to if Dmitry
were to win this game
that puts them in a tie for the lead
with our chairs night sun's so it would
all be decided tomorrow and possibly if
both players were to draw or to win then
there would be a playoff so very
exciting stuff happening in Group C yeah
do you want to stick with this gamer or
check on them on some other stuff going
on honestly I'm like we're gonna come
back to this but this looks over to me
yeah strategically over okay so why
don't we actually before we jump into
the other games take a look at the prize
fund these players are playing for and
over in Group A the total prize fund is
actually $40,000 first place in Group A
is taking home 12 K second place 9 K and
third place $7,000 and over in Group B
the total prize fund is $21,000 with
first place
taking home 6000 and second third taking
home 5004 thousand respectively over in
Group C still a substantial prize fund
but 14 thousand dollars at stake and so
the our tourism Demitri are playing for
this first place in second place of four
thousand and three thousand dollars
respectively and alright Jesse what do
you want - what do you want to look at
Nevada look at Jeffrey's team yes so
what did he decide on you know he had a
few tempting options there was very
surprising
so rook c8 97 and
as we discussed you could just play rook
a8 and castles a few if you didn't like
any of those 93 93 things right he went
rook b8 very strange moved to my eyes
now howls an incredible time pressure at
this point 91 Bishop takes Knight takes
94 I don't know if I agree with this
approach from Geoffrey I'm sure he
calculated out those lines and decided
that they weren't quite working for him
but as you know the bishops come off the
black the White King starts to look a
little bit safer
and I think White has less tough
decisions to make
well he had one tough decision here yeah
I really went for it he really went for
it here I imagine maybe I'm just totally
missing stuff but it seems like if white
wanted to he could have played the
simple rook hf1
that was position that would have been
my choice but then I noticed something
like b5 looks pretty awkward for white
to deal with good let's talk about that
whether it's true or not I guess that's
the fear so you're threatening to trip
to pieces I think right strapping the
bishop with b4 or maybe trying to trap
that night with rook v7 to c7 okay I
mean if you had time to think about it
of course if you different deal you can
play f3 here yeah you know you've got
anyway that's just the one minute on the
clock it's definitely something so let's
say this that this repeat looked weird
but it has some it has definite poison
yeah this deep b5 idea but it's weird
because 91 wasn't force either so like
yeah it's okay wait okay I take it back
the idea here with rook b8 is simply to
play Knight e4 almost no matter what and
then follow it very soon with b5
and you might even play b5 even without
playing 94 interesting yeah okay so so
subtle threats from Jeffrey maybe this
is okay so right Jeff one did not happen
instead how will 67 rook d7 King takes
rook d1 Wow and I get it close-up on
that clock but it looks like he's got
like one it's just just one minute to
Jeffrey's 23 and it's hard for me to
imagine that there's compensation here
yeah they just especially because this
Knight isn't helping so you definitely
don't want to cut off your rook on h8
there so how do you deal with this Shaq
do you play a 96 move or do you mean
let's just say I go here I can also go
King e6 yeah I don't know it's it's
tough to say really I think anything
looks fine for Jeffrey it might not be
that tough to say right thank you
/ yeah so there's Jeffrey has that
pleasant choice I guess part of the
ideas if he goes here there's at least a
check there's yeah I don't I never enjoy
running the King out in front of my
pawns like this but Jeffrey has the time
thankfully to actually calculate these
these lines out and honestly even if he
went back here I still don't think White
has anything at all special yeah maybe
nothing special but you can say he's
achieved something right he's managed to
force the rook on h8 to work a little
bit to get into the game sure but still
that says this guy's not working yes
like I don't know what I mean even here
I guess it's pretty simple to just play
something like f6 or probably f5 and
then king f7 right yeah and any time
this night goes let's say
we chop it and stuff yeah anyways King
e8 not the most intuitive move I was
just pointing out that black has several
options after this rip d1 how old true
desperation and maybe I think you know
it's funny
in hindsight if he loses this game he
might create a narrative for himself
that it was this pairing thing yeah that
husband is a mistake he could have
looked it was a natural mistake to make
of course you had to just assume that it
would all be the same but as we heard it
has to do with people somebody getting
three blacks in a row so we have a very
very difficult position here for David
Howell and our key matchups look to be
going not so well for the leaders coming
in so let's take a look at low Liam's
game and he has a chance he would rise
to the top of course him also leading
leading the event along with David
Howell I thought this was a really
interesting game from the start and
especially this plan we're gonna see
from the BM just take it through here um
Gawain played this Bishop c5 earlier on
in the tournament so a I'm definitely
knit was coming and this it's kind of
interesting take on c6 there's old so
many modern openings that are now kind
of based on this idea the pawn weakness
but then in compensation black gets the
unopposed light square bishop right the
Rosalie mo for example in the Sicilian
as we're seeing at the in Croatia as
well Knight bTW - we do this thing I did
not understand it a Ford that much but
okay it seemed to me like black was
basically fine
but here he starts to add what I call
the checkers when I saw it was upstairs
watching say like this looks like
checkers because he puts all his pawns
on the blacks coarsely and now here's a
funny thing I think Wayne's intuition
was something like well if I nail the d3
pawn what I can do is a strategy is I
can just build up against the thing and
it sound it seems like it's working
right here but watch what lilium does g3
91 and now notice the night on e 1 is a
miserable piston but it defends d3 its
miserably useful right you know it's
it's a very important purpose that it
serves and so now we're getting into
this interesting debate of our white
spawns week or are they strong and right
away
lilium is like I'm gonna neglect my
development and play f5 so I'm gonna
dominate your night I'm gonna give your
Bishop which previously was a checker
piece right I'm gonna give him this nice
dark square and so the 2nd f5 happens
the game is going to be set for where
we're going to start talking about
whether Gawain can just simply blockade
the dark squares and then be better and
that's the narrative that's going on
even now I think what this started on 22
and so our current move is 33 so that's
11 moves later it's still the same
battle essentially yeah so h6 dark
squares 97
Bishop e5 and note that the knight on g2
is thinking about 93-95 1/9 of 6 and I
think this is interesting and that
although I believe in blacks position on
a practical level it's gonna be hard to
not have a bomb hit you in the face
right so rip d6 nice move it's a dark
squares so you're just trying to fight
for do you know make the defense and
hold the line yeah you're already got to
be calculating Bishop takes h6 on every
turn here at every turn
oh but then uh the bishops get traded
that's interesting but look so he's
saying this is what I was driving at
with this d3 pawn earlier white says
look it is a weakness but my knight
moves out of the way so my rooks could
come through and now it's a miserable
piece but you're it's taking care of
both of your looks there's some very
interesting symmetry here I think
between the night on e1 and the night on
e a great the 998 though is gonna have a
future we don't know what it is yeah in
fact let's say that that's part of the
question mark for Gawain now is to find
his knight a useful square and on a1 the
knight is also always threatening to
destroy the blockade with Knight f3
so as from let's call it a classical
chess perspective I would like to
believe in the black position but I know
that there are so many bombs that can
hit you here Queen f4 and 97 are the
first moves that come to mind I'd like
to put my knight on e5 you're gonna
dream for a while feels like a very
tight rope to walk for going here but if
he manages to you know get to the other
side there's some definite bonuses to
his position right and
Gwaine of course could because he's
English is in big-time pressure yeah I
think you know I talked to him last
night he knows a little bit nervous
about this game he it's an interesting
thing for him he just recently crossed
2,700 and it's so hard to maintain that
level and I think he if he finishes one
and a half out of two in these last two
rounds he will maintain 2700 exactly
he's now minus one for the tournament so
he has to go to him and just to hold the
2700 and very difficult obviously if he
loses this game that's it it's no so
competitive for these little morsels
that were fighting for here
yeah every game has has a lot at stake I
do want to mention we have a result in
the B group right vaana's kuboos Ian did
lose his game against Daniel Freedman
who was rounding out the B group so
Daniel coming back on for maybe although
he had quite the shaky game today I
think for both players right and and one
thing I want to mention before we get
into this game is that after we went off
the air yesterday go Busey and ended up
losing to Kovalenko from a position
where I felt he was I don't know if he
was better but I liked it it was
beautiful romantic Jess and then
Kovalenko ended about playing him and we
spent some time in that that end game
yeah right and so I feel like this
opening that he played it looked to me
like he was on tilt it so it starts off
normal is this all normal business a 494
this is all kind of known stuff
now though it gets weird
where he allows this and says okay black
you can do all kinds of things you can
play how they might have my Jeep on I
don't want my Jeep well not only the
Jeep on which I thought honestly was a
risky decision I thought like I didn't
understand what white was gonna do after
Queen g5 right I thought any of these
Knight moves had to be reasonable and
you know some kind of very basic
developing move somewhere with the
bishop has to be okay as well there's no
discovery yet on this point anyway so he
took and I think black is actually just
fundamentally okay here but the next
movie he misses a beautiful shot by good
boo xenon the next move so first of all
I just let's say the moosian begins this
game on tilt that's it's like this is
huge it's a hugely problematic position
for him because the king is permanently
week and the rooks are probably never
gonna be connected but Knight c5 was
definitely a mistake because boo boo Z
and finds this very nice Bishop b5
excellent and there's actually no easy
way to deal with Oh while you're looking
at this game yeah oh we actually have
Daniel Friedman here if you wanted to
have a quick chat with him about his
game and see what his thoughts were on
these position if he likes sure so I'm
gonna step out of the studio for a
moment while we get Daniel in here okay
so while he's coming in let me just look
at Sam's game which I thought he was
worse earlier on and let's just see if
that's stayed the case yeah it looks
like he's still a little bit worse here
with Kovalenko who has had a number of
good results including yesterday as we
said against the boos Ian it was a very
interesting position where like let's
just roll through it here
number of different ways black can play
and I did not totally understand this
position I thought white was already a
little bit better here so we're going to
come back to this game after our
interview with Daniel Friedman and will
it get his goodness position his opinion
on this game maybe he was taking a look
at it during the round
so Daniel interesting game I felt like
after yesterday maybe good boozing was a
little bit on tilt the way he played
that opening yes I was quite happy with
that opening because I thought he was
expecting Queen's Gambit but I normally
play but then I thought okay he prepared
something you know some slight advantage
for white and trying to press for
nothing and okay so that I played this
line many times actually and I think he
never played this and yes five yeah this
is this is the old style the old style
right okay all style that's Knight b27
so classical Moroni sixes like normal
game not sure that F was the best moves
but okay it's different ideas you can
take on c5 and I've been try was a four
but okay in the game I was quite happy
with my opening also b3 was a bit a
surprise for me right because it's just
too slow but maybe the position after
all it's not that clear okay normal
would be just play I don't take on f6
first because if she takes in the six
first I think I have to take with an
ayat' otherwise you will play Bishop Eve
for stopping me from playing Bishop d7
so maybe just take on the six take on f6
and then just Castle yeah after Bishop
just taken c5 we need to and then maybe
for my queen I do but felt comfortable
with my position
yeah yeah so let's see what happens
we've got this and okay here I was here
is like one woman I thought maybe he can
play queen of sui here but it doesn't
work right because of night c5 I think
quinion
takes on f6 quintics of six or something
maybe actually was upon also then take
on this round play e5 and then it's
queenie for yeah and she are sorta just
yeah i think you're already better after
this b3 thing yeah also such so but
maybe it's not so clear but then we
started to play like 1700 I'm not
insulting 700 play this game but I
thought you had a huge choice of
different yeah I was considering playing
Queen g5f in d5 but then I thought you
play something like in the game Queen e2
and then trying to Castle I quickly and
my [ __ ] little bit exposed so I don't
think I can really take on h1 twice and
because if sui and maybe my bishop is
traps so I thought it's like normal idea
just take on g2 and play Bishop d7 don't
Bishop Bishop discern just to protect a
6-pound controlling CH square so she
plays Queen c2 for example then I can
look see it Queen it to but now I just
started to like was a second move of
duration instead of playing if I have
not so far so terrible unbelievable just
that's so you totally messed I mean
obviously yeah I think e5
you got a lot I was all kinds of diffuse
because his pieces aren't really
coordinated right no but okay Knight a5
is a stress so I have to do something
I mean okay maybe it's not a huge threat
but okay some moves like Knight d5 or
what
I mean he is threatening something it's
not that I can just develop my business
easily or something I cannot move my
bishop from my faith now because of this
night of five and then just seven this
thing every single thing okay moving my
Quinn from f6 is also not a good option
I think it could be all stuff kind of
like Knight takes it saves on Queen h5
check something
I don't know so I think if I if it's
where the logical more I could change
tonight this looks weird but maybe it's
I don't know what is that neither five
you just owe you what you want something
like that okay 96 and then just kill
yourself yeah something like that yeah
that's that's maybe more scary if you
were to deal with I don't know possible
okay one second after vision to see
well they're telling me we should go a
little quicker okay so so he kind of
definitely tricked you got a nice
position and actually let me just ask
your intuition I thought the easy thing
for him to do it just be the Train Queen
yeah
just treat Queens and then okay this
moment able after we should be
firefighters which to the mall so not
losing twenty moves so I thought okay
and no it's time and it's probably lost
but I have some play with night on c5
mystery it's like hanging through and an
e Phi F at some moment but clearly I
think is why haven't decisive advantage
but not so obvious maybe like you cannot
play it just was a hand like move move
move and then resign Yeah right because
here you know yeah it just started to
play a bit strange but maybe he missed
rook c5 you know I felt like it's funny
it's like I kind of wanted to go back
and trade York we'd somehow but yeah
this is the both players were thinking a
lot I was up there watching you guys
taking a lot of Miss unfortunately not
that's why that happens I think so play
too quickly in the opening and then
right when it's already too late you
start to think and then yeah nice if I'm
back and then here's here's the big
blunder right still I mean it's blunder
of course but I thought he will play
Ruby to simply I'm just preventing me
from playing comes into lately and yeah
so let's show the the trick here I
assume yeah but here's the point that he
can click after Roxy - you can play
queen h5 never and this position that's
right so clear aqua nursery it's not not
clear which one so we're already if you
play 95 it's clear that you intended to
sure but still I mean after I played the
Roxy to her so that he blonde repeat I
actually hear he not yes because he was
I'm happy that I played the Roxy - I
thought he saw dust
I didn't replace rooted to take on b2
and the guy was completely shocked right
but if he would see this I think we know
it's really interesting it's not so
clear maybe white is still better right
just because blacks not the power
and all that other stuff yeah because of
just seven and just just a tactic and
then I did six on the queerness hang in
this position
well chess fans it can happen to anybody
well congratulations and that must feel
good after just just to get on the board
you know sure feels good but the level
of the game of course disturbing from
your experience on these later rounds
just weird stuff happens in the later
rounds right but okay also before and if
we look at my game against Cavalia mukha
when he was winning like ten times in
the role like from plus 8y plus three
every move at the end I was even better
maybe winning also and so on I don't
think it's exactly have something to do
with the last round but maybe sure I
mean you get tired and then normally
such a games shouldn't happen of so many
blunders okay good well we'll hopefully
talk to you again tomorrow and then good
luck in your final game okay thing
alright thank you okay so we are gonna
take a look at what's going on in the a
group and in particular we want to see
what's going on with Jeffry and David
Jeffery does seem to have found a
winning a plan let's see how we've got
there it was rook d1 he did play the
natural king c7 and Knight c5 really
white as absolutely nothing and even had
to give up his rook so I'm gonna say
this is already already completely over
progressed quite a bit since I since I
left the chair here the good news for
how is he's managed to move quick enough
it's gated in 43 he's gained time good
for him but honestly I think most
players would resign here but and that's
when you full with the Adreno
at least go to time control so big
victory for Jeffry let's just assume he
wins what does that bring him to
understand that would tie him with Lee
and Lee assuming a draw in his game okay
so that things this is the next
interesting question where a bunch of
stuff has happened so yeah if Lee and
Lee wins this game he will be the sole
leader going into the final round with
the jaw he will be tied with Geoffrey
Zhang assuming a win in that game so a
lot of stake here for the Vietnamese
number one player okay so here we go 27
Queen f4 Queen d7 and here's White's
critical moment and he goes for it yeah
Evon taking away those those left
squares well what it's gonna do though
is that net6
you kind of if you're gonna go for it
you need to go for it this way and then
just it's a question of how much this
white half here so what is f6 I guess
this is the big question f6 was in fact
played yeah Gawain has now under a
minute often this looks like a very very
serious threat what what do you what do
you do with black we have to worry about
pawn takes f6 you have to worry about
rook takes h6 you have to worry about
those two things I think
well obviously Gawain is trying to base
his defense on this pressure on f3
like okay it looks it does look terrible
there's no there's no doubting it how
bad it is
maybe we should zoom in on the players
there and see but time situation so it
looks like he's down two seconds he
plays ugh
five seconds through six seconds on the
clock I don't like it how did you play
Queen aged six you do that let's see
that looks very very nice just put that
on the board and see it very shoot
something we take same chicks is way
buddy
so just 30 seconds oh I'm so long I'm
sorry I mean you can stop the mate with
Queen takes at three but then that
that's just hopeless yeah we see resigns
white wins wow this is huge for the
standings so Liam Lee will be leading by
a full half point over Geoffrey Jean
going into the final around and that's
if Geoffrey wins his games I think we
should get Lily em in here if we can I
would love to I think this was a real
very interesting positional game yeah
again with this idea of saying that the
d3 pawn isn't that big of a deal I can
hold it and as compensation for that I
get these monster center pawns and then
the finish is very nice because you
commit to this e5 and push you allow the
rooks what they wanted but now the King
is completely cut off from all his
friends and I don't you know I was
looking at things maybe like King 87
but there's mold and problems with this
is Richie 7 right she said this is matin
- so I don't I guess there's absolutely
nothing yeah
this f6 idea very reminiscent of the
Garry Kasparov days for me right you
would see this idea very often where you
would simply just put something in the
way of all the pieces and then the King
finds himself isolated so of course all
the defenders we have the rook on d6 -
no the Queen on c6 but nothing can come
back to help that King and as we said
before the gut bummer is you know this
tournament isn't just about first place
it's about who can retain the honor of
the 2700 club and with that Gawain has
lost it yeah Wow
so big news for Group A and we'll give
Liam Leah some time to get down here
let's take a look at what's going on in
the final game in Group A right I did
want to mention really quick thank you
to Andrew Mullen RA who gave us some
money through YouTube oh very much
appreciated a very first look seems like
Sam might be able to hold on to his
extra point is it it's probably not
gonna be enough to win because he's got
other problems but at least looks like
he's gonna be able to take the pawn Wow
okay you can take age 7 and then I guess
the problem for me is what's happening
after rook c3 just attacking c6 well
first of all it's black smooth so yes
okay 7 Rick c3 named c3 check
King D - right yeah the only way to
avoid losing the bishop and now I can
think about Bishop d6 and maybe I can
throw in so what is this
it's Sam has got 14 minutes so Dario
will have little it's his move is
probably forced so it's that well
actually Saints considering playing
something like c5 here first maybe and
the other funny thing about this
position is that when white takes on h7
maybe white could tell himself that when
he recaptures that if he just took on h7
with the rook that maybe he's just
holding yeah that as well but that one
doesn't look so doesn't look like so
much fun especially with the a3 be for a
complex in that endgame right I don't
know this bonds might be weak over there
well no that's that's what I'm saying is
that it's gonna be tough to hold with
the pawns on a 3 and B 4 no I was saying
the opposite though these guys were weak
okay you know well but anyway that's so
I think we actually have Liam Lee here
ready to come into the studio so once
again I will leave my chair and let Liam
Lee come in to talk about his wonderful
game that he played today it's going
Jones so while we're waiting for him
we're just gonna look at this rook h7
did happen just kind of let's call it
the natural move and rook c3 and now if
Sam wants an advantage he has to find
something special in addition to moves
we talked about before actually rook h2
looks like something to at least be
considered under cage to though
something like Bishop c1 could happen so
it seems like whites should be able to
hold the bounce but Sam is gonna try to
grind him out here all right so in here
as I said before I thought this was a
wonderful positional victory here so
Livia congratulations that was a
beautiful win yeah we're let's run
through the opening you tell me when we
should talk of what what we should talk
about yeah you expected this one of the
things you expect yeah and I chose this
sign lie okay it's not supposed to be
white so much but it's a long game right
so I think I got what I wanted after the
opening might be very very slight
advantage sure yeah after a four
understand I don't think you need to
play a five you tell me what the idea of
a forest well in some cases I may want
to play a five to fix the structure and
yeah I just want to provoke a five
because in some lies where I go nicely
for he could take me see and then be
five so I thought if I managed to get a
boy like that he doesn't get the b5 idea
right so maybe a case where the threat
of a five is greater than the execution
that was very tricky because now after
94 he takes yeah he after BC I was happy
because I mean I have more space and it
can play on both the green side of the
King side and he quickly does this thing
where it looks his position looks like a
checkerboard pretty soon I don't know if
he thought about that during the game it
was like all the points now go to dark
squares yeah but I'm in his place very
logically he shouldn't get in too much
trouble I think you think he's still
okay
so Bishop g5 is I try to get a temple
because otherwise this squidman comes
with f6 and he's sick so yeah I want to
go to e3 but first I put a mission once
you find so yeah I think maybe he could
play Bishop e6 bad I don't know
yeah the why he play also looks logical
putting the bishop on f6 but I think it
may be a little misplace can again he
can't get away with something weird like
95 yeah I thought about that move e5 c5
Bishop e3 shops e3 and I have new phones
and he doesn't he doesn't have time to
take on any form so let's just show
Ricky four okay so he has to go back to
shop before
instead of Brook before but then I get
response going a five f1 so all right so
a lot of lot of stuff behind the scenes
okay so let me just put into words in my
layman's understanding of what happened
right my amateurs mind under stay would
happen is that he created a story for
himself here where he was gonna play
against this pawn and you know say that
that was gonna maybe even be okay or
better for him but then you said it's
only one weakness right and then played
this incredible left for is that kind of
roughly what happened yeah I mean at
some point I guess it has to play c5
because otherwise when you fall so he
has to play c5 n after c5 basically d4
almost never work for me because you can
trade everything and get a good square
for the knight that's right right so I
don't see any other plan for me
sure so I have to go f4 and try to take
with AF widow cheapo and that's the main
idea alright I do get some space so I
think EF has to be the critical move
because otherwise I play five and that's
all right so yeah yeah it's a little bit
tricky because it's hard to get my rook
b1 to the game don't be worried as
always before and the three points week
so there's some kind of threat like mr.
H 496 nice one so it's not so easy here
to decide what to do the midgets acid
did you feel you were better in this
position I wasn't sure if I'm better but
I thought I shouldn't be worth here okay
yeah I thought it was real I thought to
me it was very interesting because you
know you played this it's like you're
playing without for at least a while you
know you're playing without the knight
and the rook and then you're just calmly
taking these and this was very I think
it's a right move it's very committal
right because now he's gonna try to
occupy he fine yeah I give him the e5
square but the thing is if I don't play
five then he may have he might have
something like ninety six and the net
will be really annoying on this 45 I
think the critical move should be
Bishop s4 so forcing me to go Bishop f2
otherwise I'm losing upon oh that's
critical okay yeah yeah so then take and
I have to take with rook and then
perhaps Queen d6 and try to get a 95
so it is similar to the game but he
might say he's a champion yes fast
listeners and if they couldn't get my
room out so I have to spend some some
time like f3 yeah I was thinking but I
think it's team up listen for me because
that's really interesting i cuz every
time I look at this I'm like oh blacks
gotta be okay
because of this but then no it's not
that easy right yeah that's really
interesting to me I didn't yeah the only
thing is that I have to be careful with
my opponent d3 that's yeah yeah but like
you said it's your only weakness so if
you can just hold that weight because
one day it's night before I missed again
you have other ways of reorganizing
maybe King each one but but then ninety
seven ninety three and if you trade a
night I think again I would rather be
black okay but yeah I see if you can
treat nice it should be safe so
definitely though for this it's clear
that this is much better than what
happens right yeah
yeah cuz in the game he also trade the
bishop the bishops later on but he yeah
he gave me some time to consolidate my
position right and so h6 it felt to me
like this like a very old style move
with age six where he's playing on the
dark squares and you know wants to do
this and all 97 stuff but right I guess
too slow because let's see how you do it
now all of a sudden your pieces start
finding squares and in particular now as
long as you're working it over then your
knight goes back and then it's like oh
no oh no that the Knights terrible
anyone but it's doing all the work in
the world they actually I think bd8 was
his mistake okay
because if you just sit there I'm not
sure how I would improve yeah because
the thing is after rook b8 and I took
any 525 91 and there's all kinds of
threats on the Kings side so I was
thinking maybe he should
all right obviously I don't understand
the position as well as you do but let
me just make a move for you and you tell
me what's yeah yeah try to bring the
Queen and okay even here though maybe
you sacked exchange and say yeah that's
art square so that's a possibility yeah
yeah I can do that okay yeah so it's
funny I still believe in blacks position
but you showed something interesting I
think with this night holding on because
this position all of a sudden now he's
an even though he technically has the
dark squares he is in big trouble
yeah big trouble because 9-3 is a very
strong threat and I think maybe
initially he's at 97 he could play but
[Music]
not could you - but default yeah that's
really cruel yeah yeah same thing with
let me try to defend for the guy Oh snip
snip see five
yeah you can do that
if I won't take right but maybe there's
Queen c2 and roguish for coming
so you have to go to create but that
looks powerful
I don't know if this looks right or
feels right but can I do that that
doesn't look right
[Laughter]
okay yeah that's so that was a good yeah
D for its it's so surprising that you're
then even able to do this like right
that's what blacks intention to hold you
back yeah okay so let's look at the
finish 98
yeah at first I also missed this idea
Quincy one that's why I repeated one
time with crew chief on uh-huh but then
okay I realized this Quincy one is very
strong wolf and I mean at first I think
his intention was to take on D 3 and
sack the exchange but it doesn't work
because of green ticks and six
otherwise this Quincy one so D 3 and I
guess you do it right now yeah and you
just add first you for whatever reason
you did see it right away
okay yeah when I see there's no defense
because the idea of Quincy wanted to
take away the Foursquare right my nights
to come in three so yeah and there's no
defense against this threat of 9 3 D 5
and the sad thing for him that I was
thinking it's like this Knight is doing
a hero's job because it really did
defense this guy
Plus as we see in the game it can pop
out to break the blockade right words
but the bummer is this guy's not doing
anything if he was just doing something
then we could believe in blacks position
but you know it's not working so let's
look at this very nice finish Queen e7
Queen f4 and really with that you've
broken the blockade
and check route d3 f6 yeah so let's show
one more move Queen h6 beautiful
beautiful so you are now you have a
chance at winning the tournament yeah
well it looks like how will lost so the
tournament is wide open and who are you
playing tomorrow okay let's get your
opinion actually why you're here we have
to look at this game yeah definitely
bluff is pushing for the win what's
what's going on if I just do this and
then take this pawn yes probably his
idea is defo just activate the bishop
and then maybe yeah so maybe just repeat
maybe but then there's some route a7
yeah it seems like
maybe you have to do it
he in the game he did take on g5 he
hasn't taken on a6 yet I'm thinking
maybe it's better for where to start
with we should be five instead of taking
on a six for example it so there might
be some
I'm just trying to make a drawing media
today but well I think that can be a why
what's wrong with whites position after
okay six though probably the best moment
so let's say
okay so let's just let's just run and
see what happens so b5 g ba g 4 b 6g 3
no g3 b7 and then you can't do that oh
but you could be late
no big because when you check no you
could check and then play Bishop f4 oh
that's right yeah
so let's do 3 and I can't go D 1 because
of Rafi - right so I gotta go here is
actually winning because Bishop b4 days
Bishop e3
well it's not well hold on but on g2 I
could I can make a queen and go to a -
right and that's right so you should
first start with you to not be sure to 5
then it's winning okay G - yeah
so you have to play Bishop me for now
Bishop c5 we should be three king be one
maybe also be to be three but no but
repeated yeah so yeah whoa okay so yes
there is hidden drama if rook takes a
six with the first what we did was we
played rookie - and it looks kind of
weird but right we have we need to make
it difficult for white to do things like
Bishop e5 and we're just pushing it oh
that's that was an interesting variation
let's let's try that again
b5 tell me if you want to do any okay
that's the way far but that's why should
bill Bishop e5 just popping the phone
it's a it's kind of definitely a bummer
to put it on that square oh but II five
now yeah yeah yeah this is not good for
white
so you throw maybe interesting so right
this is what dar was thinking about
whether you should do it definitely if
he doesn't take the hornies gonna suffer
for sure right there's yeah yeah but I
have a feeling that if Y depends that
correctly should be draw it see it
definitely feels that way right so what
are we thinking
rooks
maybe it is difficult
so let's say rook takes rupee - maybe
Bishop e5 immediately so if rule 34
maybe Bishop me six straight again the
temple we should know these things
so let's just assume that if you trade
that it's a draw
is that fair Phil yeah okay so I'll play
then up that one okay and now be fine
now maybe what is the way there's a
trick maybe mr. d6 can I is this a
meaningful trick well b2 I can at least
get a check
and then something like Bishop f6 is
your attempt right yeah but now I'm
worried about it let me put that maybe
yeah okay well I think we're gonna get
Geoffrey Jean in here talk about his
game okay and so we'll definitely be
following you in the final round it's
gonna be an exciting one and so good
luck thank you a beautiful game today I
really enjoyed all right so we're gonna
be keeping our eye on that game with Sam
and while we're waiting for Jeffrey to
come in I just want to roll through some
of the other results here Igor beat
Samuel Savion and so that's critical for
the standings and in our game of the day
with Ganguly against Oprah which I wish
we had had more time to talk about we
still have a complete mess but I think
at least Ganguly is not totally lost or
anything before I definitely thought his
position was critical and in Group C
let's just say we have complete madness
Akopian beat trilha and L Shawn against
Brandon let's let's just guess that
that's a draw and then in the very
important game would make sense and
Gordievsky let's let's guess let's guess
that it's a win for our source but we
don't know we have Jeffrey Zhang in here
with us with a very interesting game and
why don't we start Jeffrey with 97 yes
it was it was played by a few strong
grandmasters but I believe maybe in like
speed chess so completely serious and I
checked it out and it seems it's
actually I play a similar line for white
when I play d4 Knight f6 Knight of three
g6 and I sometimes play Knight Beauty -
uh-huh
so yeah it's similar like if you were to
play d4 my idea would be
you fine and I would be kind of playing
those positions at temper down and yeah
I thought okay worth it worth a shot
and did you play into the idea that you
you said to yourself this guy gets in
time pressure so if I do something weird
yeah yeah I I had this this thought yeah
it's okay I expected that he would spend
some time here to figure out what I'm
trying to do
okay so c4 again I thought you'd played
well but but unconventional yeah
unconventional maybe maybe he should
have played Bishop g2 here yeah he was
afraid of night of five and he didn't
understand how to protect his pawn d4
Knight b6 thing is direct although I
think it's possible for him to just give
it up like for example castles Knight b6
Queen c2 Knight d4 Knight d4 if I take
with the Queenie's he grabs c7 and
Bishop takes his also unadvised
unadvisable because what d1 is an issue
so yeah probably he should have actually
just developed in the natural way Rea
it's almost like he made things way more
complicated although I think yes I know
he may have missed this like he never
missed Knight a5 Bishop f4 the night
before long castles is a nice idea but
I've gotten 97 I mean I think maybe he
over because but although it's not like
he's in he's in any trouble I think but
he was already in time pressure yeah he
was in time pressure and it's getting a
little bit sharp instead of long castles
I think it was more practically simply
to take go for this kind of equal ish
ending
before Queen c7 I can I have moves like
I can take I don't have to take I can
also cancel her Bishop e6 mm-hmm but in
at the end of the day I believe it's
it's a it's too symmetrical and should
end in a draw for example Bishop e6
let's just say Bishop g2 keep it very
simple eventually I suppose I should
take on c7 all right he takes rook c8
this should be six yeah I think that
yeah you have multiple plants here to
you you could probably take and take on
c3 as well if you wanted to be a madman
I could yeah I thought about that take
six takes takes and Bishop d5 and try to
try to play play this kind of structure
all right although I assume that it
should be around equal in all the cases
okay so yeah this is very risky
okay so let's assume you miss 97 mm-hmm
and then we have to ask ourselves how
bad is this position yeah I don't think
it's so bad but it's somehow as king is
always in a little in a little bit of
danger and okay so but he might have
we're discussing 95 he might actually
have 95 right I thought that was his
intention yeah yeah I think he was
afraid of b6 because now his Bishop is
kind of trapped efore is critical this
should be 7 this should be 5 and I think
he just couldn't work out the tactic so
the point is if I think rook c8 should
be the move
and yeah he missed mr. smooth King be
one simple and the ideas if he if I take
on c7 with the night I think he takes on
d7 King be seven and Knight b6 although
no I missed actually I miscalculated
because I have I have Keaney egg here
and if Knights did I take on e4 so
actually I miss kind of late
let's come back so there b6 yeah II
thought this should be 7 there should be
five like c8 I thought Kim b1 was the
new
nine of six dozen
that's barium was right not to go
actually then it's yes and I thought can
be one were sad to stay calm
okay well let's look at this position
and just yeah so then what he played was
absolutely correct Bishop d7 he has he
has a lot of options here again I was
expecting easy for but it's it's quite
risky like II for let's say I could try
to take on c3 this is interesting my
ideas if he takes I will take on e4 and
okay this should be five looks natural
or in this position yeah in this
position
Bishop f3 but it's kind of funny because
after rook d7 I think I can just take
take on h1 that's funny and the rook on
a it is protected so okay so just king
of fate and okay he goes rookie seven I
go Keane da and I think he doesn't have
sufficient compensation for the rook
right yeah we were looking at but yeah
he can after Bishop c3 King he could
play this should be fine events my right
away and yeah now it's not clear I mean
I can if I Cal so he takes on d7 with
the book says yeah it's not clear that's
why probably I would have gone for after
an e4 I would have gone for rook c8 you
maybe you can just this is insane
you do that yeah [ __ ] before now he
will take on d7 with the room yeah okay
actually mainly maybe Bishop f3 yeah the
broom Bishop 3 he will take on e7 and my
Bishop is at least cover you covered the
game actually okay I have no idea what's
this - but wait actually he doesn't have
to take on e7 maybe you know here
yeah rook I'm not sure no I'm probably
just going okay but it's not sure it
would have gone for this because somehow
I mean this mission is okay but sometime
after work the saying that looks very
scary yeah yeah of course yeah yeah yeah
you know and already here I think he was
down two minutes yes so here's the move
I guess if he was here I'd ask him it
just felt night be fine felt really
strange to me I yeah I was I wasn't
expecting although I don't think it's
such a bad move to be honest and the
point is I I think I want to take on c3
and 84 either now here on the next move
and in the meantime it's not easy for
him to find a move I mean if you just
I'm guessing just what something like
that let's look at 91 g2 and now I can
play rook state or I could try to be
greedy and take right away take on c3 BC
and 84 I'm probably gonna give you one
yeah you have to give me okay
yeah and but now maybe just might be fun
even work c8 looks good too
whoops he does look good I agree so this
position might be close to losing okay
so right if that's so Knight me maybe
five is clearly the move of a desperate
man yeah I mean okay the other thing I
was thinking about was like if he could
try Knight d5 but I don't think it's
it's also not very appealing I have to
rook c8 he moves the King and then I
just kicked the knight so yeah actually
it's not the the bummer is that this guy
is just out and this guy is pretty out
yeah yeah my bits are beautiful and it's
his king that's really under attack okay
well I think what he did was 95 we were
I thought I tell you had several
pleasant choices here and you of course
got to think about it for a while yeah I
think this is you actually calculated
well because so these concrete checks
like 93 can be won there should be four
III the issue is that I can't actually I
don't have time to move my knight with a
problem wherever I move the rook he's
just gonna keep attacking right yeah we
looked at this and it's the if here then
he comes back and he's hitting here so
the break there was so many things you
could do here in addition I felt like if
you wanted to you could just Castle and
I thought you know better there to the
point yeah originally I wanted to castle
actually but now I didn't see what I
could do so let's say 91 very strange
that it looks nice but what happens is
if he gets the lights where bishops
trade which I think he does then this
knight on b5 it's hard to kick
and I see if it kind of stays there it's
hard for me to to do things okay okay
so yeah rook ba yeah that's why I tried
to be the clever here with Ruby and it
actually worked because he he blundered
right away I I was thinking okay he has
two natural moves here I guess
King be winner or Knight d5 back when I
decide somehow I like King do one more
because maybe the Nano a7 has a future
if it can come to c6 and okay let's try
Kings e1 and you have King b1
I thought maybe b5 yeah we're discussing
b5 but the point is now at least he can
take on c5 so he doesn't have to worry
about this chip shot and now
although I agree that and look at it now
it's very very Shady
yeah I'm just worried about you worried
about your poor night you've got several
moves here honestly 94 yeah I like 94
looks he probably well at least he's got
93 so he can cover some things
I mean probably counsel me looks good
yeah giving if I take on b5 like that in
here yeah yeah I thought all kinds of
discoveries yeah okay well let's just
roll through what happened and this was
full desperation I fell here yes the
promise I mean if not route d7 I've got
to do a threat if he plays something
simple look at 4 B 5 is e 5 isn't having
two very nice yeah that was that was I
guess your key idea whether it be a yeah
exactly yeah and when they make a book
about you they're gonna include this
because it's pretty triggers ready
tricky move yeah okay good so what are
you what are you at now Jeffrey
after this one I'm on plus one plus one
okay so tournament wide open for you and
here right you are who you playing next
round white against Schwartz okay so
that oh this this tournament especially
the a group is wide open wide open today
alright well hopefully we'll have you
back in tomorrow and thank you sir game
thank you
alright I think we might get another
interview in while we're waiting for
that let's take a look at everything
that's happened when the Samuel Shanklin
game as you remember we were kind of
looking very similar ideas to this
position with Liam and instead of g4
here we're looking at route e to for Sam
but let's look at Sam's idea G for
Bishop e5 rookie 2 rookies 70 here's a
funny thing though the n-doped we looked
at this and that's why we were playing
he came up with the idea of playing
rookie to be for g4 precisely so that
after a wreck a7 there's no threat I'm
Bishop d6 so King EA didn't happen and
my very first impression is that if
white wants a draw now he can get it
with checking on a8 and going back
he might dream about more but I think
that's kind of a forced situation there
wait escaping with the draw maybe yeah
and maybe it was a draw the whole time
it was just Lilian had this cool idea of
delaying the natural G for and playing
rookie - - you know because busy father
has to come and you just want to hit him
before work a7 comes very well yeah it's
good to be back in the chair I did just
want to say thanks to a liam lee and
geoffrey jean for sharing their very
interesting thoughts on their games in
the tournament situation as well so it's
been a minute why don't we do a quick
check up on all the groups and see where
they stand okay yeah let's do it
I need help thank you so much stuff so
many violent things have happened so
this is the last game in the a group
right like the least relevant one for
the standings and with a draw I think
that pretty much eliminates both of
these players from fighting for that for
the top spot if Sam somehow won this
thing wouldn't have a chance
everything's white hit then right so
these are the two games that matter the
most we see a Gregorio / in there I
believe or no we don't that is the star
up there we see Cooley in the bottom
right there head so his game matters for
the B group it's the last one still in
play and he's paired against Gregorio
proned who is leaving the tournament
yeah there on the top left we see our
tears Mike Suns who's leading the Caesar
so these are the two relevant games for
the B group and the secret let's see
what they can do can we pull up the
standings for any of these groups and
then we'll love well we'll talk about it
a little bit cuz yeah it's all happening
we need we didn't even have a chance to
talk about Kovalenko x' win over
Savion which was very nice yes
let's wrong right while waiting on the
standings let's go to the game with
Ganguly and Oprah and before I thought
that Oberon had a very nice position and
now I'm not totally sure what's going on
it might just be that well white at
least shouldn't lose this thing yeah I
didn't lose this thing so I do want to
say with a draw grigory Oprah and will
clinch the B group so all he has to do
is draw today and the dremen is in his
hands with Sam seve and losing his game
he drops back to 50% so no one can catch
from Rory if he wins today right or if
he draws today or if he draws tomorrow
so it just needs a half point to to
clinch this out it looks to me like he's
gonna win the b-pawn and that's just
gonna be a draw but there might you know
there might be some trickiness here our
cue Polly I guess white can argue that
the the deep pond is far less relevant
than the passer on the side of the board
with this one and that this one even
though it's not a passer yet has at
least violent potential so let's think
about some of some concrete nerves I
guess rook b6 might be natural and that
takes before and what do you go where do
you go from here that's if you could do
two moves and get that in mmm that would
be nice unfortunately on g4 I guess you
just do that and then
Knight f5 in who know then no problems
for black so that's kind of the basic
problem is that this night doesn't have
any beautiful maybe something like any
tricks
Nate G for might be bringing the night a
little closer to a relevant square where
do you want to go after that so actually
CB v played in the game it's an
interesting way to give up upon no yeah
I don't know about 94 I wanted to
combine it with direct b6 to threaten
some 95 b5 looks pretty interesting okay
so the first question with b5 is what's
gonna happen
I don't think this works this looks like
a draw right it's a rook before we see
Knight c4 no maybe there's even d5 no I
think this is very dangerous very scary
I don't think you wanted that and
besides it in this position it should be
white who's pressing if anybody you know
so I don't I'm sure you some other idea
let's look 95 perhaps we could go he did
actually played a V but maybe that was
the fear here that looks like the fear I
will win the pawn yeah okay b5 excellent
so a B has played a B and now a sixth at
the very least looks scary
rook b5 also looks scary so Ganguly
Ganguly could have a little bit of
revenge yeah and a cool way you know it
looks very draw but a way to talk about
this is to say let's just say if a rook
takes I think I think a6 is also very
viable but if I can stabilize and not
lose the eight bomb which by the way
maybe I'm simply losing the eight ball
but if I can somehow stabilize that pawn
there's a strong claim to be made that
this guy is not that important so this
position is actually on the board now
and the player is kind of reaching this
pretty quickly right okay so white needs
a special move
one thought could be can I do is this
interesting rook b6 let's just say you
take for a second right mm-hmm
let's say I snip King g5 and back that
could be special
now well you don't have to go to g5 you
could say to yourself oh it's not happy
but let's say good f7 that way on this
move you could play that okay okay so
let's not even have to do this I think
this is I don't I didn't see quite what
was wrong with the line of going to g5
so let's look this very similar things
happened tonight war it's identical to
the one we were showing it yeah so he
has to make the choice now the again the
problem with going to g5 is when I go to
ace six you can't move your rook to say
e four because we're okay five and if
you touch my knight with rook a3 then I
can move the thing
yeah but then I'm I just want to play
Knight to c4 next okay so you want to do
a g5 g5 there might also be some weird
other problem here that you're creating
with yeah just please don't checkmate me
we can dream fascinating game because in
addition to being down a pawn black has
an offsides Knight and so if we just
let's just say we lifted the Knights off
the board it's obviously gonna be a draw
but if you imagine that we lifted the
Knights off the board and I was able to
remove the blockade of the King yeah
then we would have a win so this is
close so in addition to you got to worry
about this rook a six thing like we said
this game is is very close I do want to
mention that a the C group looks like
archers might be able to clinch the win
here all right so it's like he's simply
up a piece we see him there on on the
camera with a wonderful Mike comer in
the background and we have no idea we're
gonna look but when we left this game
yeah it looked like he was in big
trouble so a win here would clinch the C
group for archers one thing I really
admire about Gordievsky is even now when
he's down a piece he still has
aggressive in
very murderous intent from Dmitry here
with those this looks like it's over
let's let's just recap how this weird
thing happened here so let's go back to
this terrible terrible position that we
left where black played 97 oh and was
and then wait a second
so okay so we left it around here and I
said something like it's gotta be toast
for black white I mean for what he
excuse me looks very good for black had
several moves here he chose this one and
maybe that was a mistake I think I
mentioned but this should be six Bishop
c5 yeah because now 95 now I'm getting
the east six square and then tagging
your Bishop on d4 hmm so that was a key
blunder that was simply a blender from
Gordievsky maybe if the bishop leaves
that a 188 diagonal there is the ship c3
to be a little concerned about four
black rather than a dozen a g6 man the
good news for black is that it's okay
okay fair enough yeah but at least I
anything on the true and we needed to
provide think we needed to prevent this
Knight d5 because the rook wants to do
stuff to oh man okay so from this
position our tours are tourists let's
just say this he's made a beautiful
tournament but he's definitely gotten
some look yes in this vase quite the
escape artist sometimes check to the
misérable can just the two bishops now
this is a oh man it was not not looking
so good for black
yeah so maybe it should've well and now
this is too much at least he's still
fighting some here but yeah we're gonna
call this over and actually the couple
more moves being played and tell us what
would have happened with the standings
now
so if our turfs wins this games he jumps
up to six and a half points out of nine
it's a full +4 I believe and the next
closest player would be a Ron Paco bein
with five out of nine so you would have
a full point and a half lead going into
the last round
therefore a clinching the tournament
okay and well let's just say what's
going on here but let's just visit
briefly without Shawn and Brandon shared
this looks like a dead girl nothing well
it's not over yet if let's just say it
probably is over
kingi one just happened with black to
move would be a different story right
yes to in same but yeah you can put the
King on h1 leave that Bishop on that
long diagonal and then you can never
never be evicted I it was funny you know
I admire Brandon's play but I just want
to maybe this is incorrect with me but I
want to just share a moment here in this
position I feel like someone who is a
student of Fischer's games would have
never played rook 88 it's like a
beautiful Kings Indian position here and
one of the nice things about these
positions that Fisher showed is don't
trade rooks and don't worry about the D
file if you're gonna put your Brooke
anywhere put it on ei and so I thought
blacks should have played a move like
Queen f7 or rook a e8 and then gone to
mate then it's time for
instead he instead he traded everything
off and I don't know it just kind of all
slipped away but let's look yeah back
where the action is I want to show
another okay want me to show this one
with the count we had a very interesting
game where Rama had prepared this
novelty here with 14 e5 and the count
thought it was well actually maybe the
longest think of the tournament I'm
gonna say he thought for about 40
minutes and usually when you think for
40 minutes it's the wrong decision I
think this one was the right one he
played nine f8 and let's just look at
how this went I thought I believed in
the counts position here so queen h5
snip rook f3 g6 no I very much believed
in the count here I thought he was doing
great he seemed to have positions like
this all tournament long where his
pieces are kind of held back and then he
tries to break through with like this f5
break and stuff like this and it's
worked with varying degrees of success
but somehow it always seems to slip or
for the count this tournament well you
know one thing you have to say when you
play the Sicilian you're probably gonna
get made yeah
Queen e7 doesn't look right maybe he had
maybe it's true he has nothing better
but Queen e7 there's this nice move and
already you're unhappy with life because
if you take on g5 f G happens to you and
then and then the X blacks extra point
is pretty meaningless so in the game you
did that and that's also not what we
wanted in life okay
so though man the count count has had a
rough tournament and I just want to say
personally identify with the count
because you know I feel like he's a
little stronger than me and I
imagine going into this tournament and
facing these animals and it's not just
them being very strong it's like
especially as a slightly older guy the
count is not even close his old design
but he's older still than the average
age of the tournament participant and
you have to have energy for 10 games and
he definitely didn't have it so it looks
like her Gauri oprand is solving a lot
of his problems here that's why we see
all the players there in the key
matchups for today once again we believe
our turfs is winning his match but the
part where it's a little unclear
is this Ganguly operon game where I'm
not sure he solved his problems here the
night well if you bring your knight back
in and I will be convinced but until
that night comes back to the Kings side
I'm not well I've got a mission
actually how do I do it really okay five
was just played okay five was actually
something that looked pretty nice to me
not the convinced not the conventional
pin but the idea is very similar right
if you want to play something like rook
d7 I'm simply going to be attacking your
knight at the end of the line and of
course the rook versus rook and pawn
endgame would be a draw with the black
King in front of the pawn comfortably so
what do you even do with with white here
well it's probably not gonna work out
for you black is gonna be able to hold
the blockade is what he's saying and
that and then we're saying Oberon wins
right yeah with the draw Oprah and
clinches his championship here so he
will be the winner of the B group with
the draw today Oh Ganguly will press but
you know I guess what is the bestest God
is something I see here I wanted to
mention there's this kind of funny move
Knight d6 check but it's definitely not
working it doesn't do much you just go
here thankfully black is not forced to
capture on this right and let's just say
a lot of you know there's a rule which
says if you want to ask if the knight
end games winning you just lift the
Knights off and ask if the King endgame
is winning and the funny thing with that
rule here is white actually would be
winning with King h4 if you lifted that
nice so the key difference is there's
not there's not any puns left there's
just the one pond so the knight can
usually if it can make it back just
sacrifice to the pond right right if
I've had there's some evil end games
here if white could say have his King
here on h7 then I would be tempted to
say we could bully the Black Knight or
at least have chances but now you know
we have to break the we had to break
several blockades you know of all of
these squares of the black being able to
sit there and in the meantime right the
night is going to come back and he's
going to try to hurry carry himself the
g3 so that does look like a drawing rook
a5 it looks like yeah so you know I
think let's just briefly talk about the
critical moment somewhere around here I
felt like Oberyn was definitely for
choice yeah and he actually did one of
the plans I mentioned which was
reorganized the Knights and put him on
those beautiful f45 squares and maybe he
missed this shot here let's look
snip-snip night here that's an easy one
to miss me
yeah yeah what a bummer and then all of
a sudden nothing is as simple as it
wanted to be me originally black could
have thought himself that this was
winning but no I have rook c8 and then I
could just take on that fan so what
happens on on the obvious being F takes
e4 that's a Malaysian natural move so
check just take just take the pawn so we
see there the players have agreed to a
draw
this makes gregorio Oberon our Group B
champion of the 2019 summer chess
classic that's right so we're gonna make
an effort to get him down here in the
studio and talk about his his tournament
experience you know he's been kind of on
the sidelines for for our dream he's
just been playing very solid chests very
a reasonable chess and kind of daring
his opponents to dig their own grave and
it's worked out for him plus four is a
phenomenal score after nine rounds
that's right yeah
and we have another result with Darwin
Sam did draw in kind of the way we
expected so totally I'm sorry what was
going to happen here and we had this on
our analysis board so can we pull it you
pull up some standings pull up some
standings here we'll see where we're at
sure so uh pretty soon we'll take a look
at a group a standings so actually all
the action is done for round eight so
this is the group to keep an eye on
tomorrow this is the one where we expect
a lot of action to go on Liam Lee will
have the advantage in the final round
being a half-point up over geoffrey
Zhang Liam I believe is playing Sam
Shanklin tomorrow who was the number one
seed coming into the event so that will
be a tough game for him Jeffrey will be
trying to catch up with a win tomorrow
that would put him level with liam lea
su mning a draw from that game and
has daro spirits to face tomorrow so
those are the two games we're definitely
going to keep a very very close on and
let's just say something obvious if Sam
is gonna have white tomorrow and he's
gonna press and if he wins he will yeah
tie for first
that's Jeffrey wins and they'd every
would be ahead so both David and Sam
actually not mathematically eliminated
if Sam wins his game then he's a very
good chance to uh to be in a playoff and
if David wins his game he also has a
similar chance well he needs to do it
though he needs a lot to happen for
David but yes Sam it's definitely not
out of the question that he could be
playing for the championship tomorrow
okay I think probably take a look at a
group B standings as well what we expect
to happen so we're very open with that
draw has clinched the summer chess
classic in the B group putting himself a
full point and a half ahead of the next
closest competitors Sam seven and
actually Igor Kovalenko tie for second
Igor of course was at the bottom of the
standings coming out of the first few
rounds made a miraculous comeback
winning quite a number of games here in
the latter half monoski boos Ian and
Daniel Friedman both at four points
after nine rounds with Surya Ganguly
former tournament leader actually
rounding out with a loss today and let's
see what we expect to happen in Group C
as well so this is what we expect to
happen two of the games have finished
but we're still waiting on occurs Mike
Suns to try to pull it out in his game
so we're expecting a win from him which
would clinch the championship but it has
not happened yet around Cobian has
already definitely won his game putting
him at five points so wait we have it
listed up there as a win but it actually
isn't over so this is what we're
expecting hope no knock on wood nothing
goes wrong but so we see our turfs there
so with a win here he would clinch the
win clinched the tournament so let's
keep an eye on that position let's just
say he won here he would be seven and a
half out of nine yeah that's an absurd
score and I'm six and a half out of nine
we've six nephews excuse me so plus four
cuz it's a nap up there oh seven now
yeah so okay
is it easy here it's really easy it
should really be easy how easy would I
be able to win with the white piece well
okay let's look a little closer okay for
he's thinking about it let's say we do
the obvious looking oh maybe it won't be
so easy let's try v6 mm-hm
I'll take your part to the misérable
connect to you and now let's be a little
careful one idea is to say that here no
no that's not true actually maybe this
is so let me just show if King c3 hoping
that you're covering b2 there's
unfortunately f8 and the game isn't over
so yeah this would be a mistake of
course maybe the most natural square you
would think might be King one after okay
- but then that runs into rookie - check
right white hasn't played b6 yet does
they have any other options besides this
b6 move well I'm looking and the problem
is you you need the rook to guard
against g3 then you also need another
piece to talk to f2 and it's looking
kind of difficult to do
yeah this would be a real disaster our
tours our tours what are you doing buddy
what happened um okay what else can we
do I mean it's definitely what our tours
is considering he doesn't like something
after v6 he could consider rook h5 and
then prepare to give up the bishop and
go back it's not really what you wanted
in life I do want to mention the pawns
currently on b5 right right yeah so
we're looking here for a move for white
yep oh I think all of a sudden this is
not so pleasant for a peasant no wait a
second there's another there's another
obvious thing we need to look at I'm
waiting check Oh King d5 you could go
other places right and rookie six this
is a nice way to keep the pawn defended
however oh my goodness
it's tough to calculate this out what if
I play rook before and then simply g3
next trying to trying to make a lady
this is what he's thinking about and
honestly I don't see anything that's
special for white here but you know when
we just look at ideas for white here
it's like hoodie there's not that much
he's looking at that mm-hmm he's looking
at rook age five and he's looking at the
immediate push I'm gonna guess that when
he got to this position in his head he
was assuming that b6 would win because
that's the kind of natural thing you
just like to do maybe an unusual try
might be king
II won well you still have time to do it
try to bring that King a little bit
closer working an f1 I also check to the
miserable King King f2 King g3 check to
the miserable King okay I see see what's
happening to me
no it's it's he's he's desperate enough
he's considering that do ya so King e1
we're k2 maybe I'll play Bishop b4 and
that's a little bit different so now you
can't check me so crudely no I could
still do here
here okay well I'm not I'm not sure
what's going on here but what I do know
is we have grigory Oprah in here ready
to talk about his big draw today
clinching him the B group championship
so I don't know if we can call it a
championship but he will be the winner
of the B group in the summer chest
classic and so let's get him in the
studio well I will take my leave for a
moment all right while we're waiting I
guess we're just gonna sit around here
and think about this position we're
going to look at for our tours and our
tours you know also it's gonna get a
little bit of time pressure here and
this is the kind of thing even you know
it's it's hard to imagine but it could
go the other way if he pushes too hard
because I'm sure he believes that he's
totally winning and will be incredibly
frustrated if it's actually true that
this is not just an easy time situation
for him maybe one final ideal mention is
you could do maybe King D 3 snip and
Bishop d4 I don't really believe in that
but that's a final thought that he can
have a final thought he's thinking about
all kinds of things here but he's gonna
have to find a good move here in this
surprising position where he was just
winning before okay I have Gregorio
Oberon in with us and he drew a nice
game where I thought he was much better
at some point but the big news is
congratulations the big roof yeah well I
thought you know the whole tournament
you played very solid openings yeah
right and and you you took your chances
when you need it to so that was real
nice and in this game well I thought
maybe your opponent over pressed and you
got a nice position yeah probably I
think I'm so I was way closer after
doping it's a bit basic
especially the Bishop 107 then he
somehow allows that Bishop g5 and after
that I think I'm completely fine
right maybe you should wait instead of
c3 they can eat first takes takes Knight
c4 right just to prevent yeah I think
this one this was a more critical
approach and you feel like maybe he's a
little better here yeah I mean I still
have to somehow solve this problem is a
beautiful New Zealand I mean I can play
queenie 826 okay so good move yeah
that's the everybody who has a bad [ __ ]
27 knows about this trick that guy this
before and I see I already thought you
were better here yeah I both think I'm
better but I have a very comfortable
play I mean right right just to worry
all my pieces to f5 yet simple chance
yeah dose CT was a critical move yeah I
was a little surprised that he took
within like that but this seems to admit
that he's worse when he takes you this
way yeah so what does she do I have a d5
at the point
and that's why I put my own yet so I
protect all the squares and after I'd
say it takes 25 I can take take 28 you
create oh great think of seven oh goody
one
and now 96 because if I take on c4 he
has the g5 huh
right so we're Knight of 6 and I think
I'm completely fine right okay
still I still feel like this is what he
should probably do instead of taking
here let's maybe just here yeah but I
mean it's a variant I can take one of 85
at some point right yeah you're gonna
take on a 5 it's yeah but maybe maybe
first I can take one before event
and now it could Kobe steak well he
that's some compensation or something
yeah but well that was his choice that I
guess he decided he didn't want this and
after this you get this right
I felt very nice play with your nights
here you know is one night because the
seven is not that great so far but yeah
well we were talking about this and we
said already in the broadcast that
already you were dreaming of this setup
and that's what you do right yeah so
this all you know I'm sure you could
have done different moves here yeah
these are all pretty natural and yeah
here actually we discussed a bit after
the game I think maybe Luke eight of
seven is better instead of King AJ yeah
okay just so that you have more sorry
let's say if you place h3y kids again I
can play h5 queen f2 and now can play g4
because he doesn't have that check on h4
right okay so I'm gonna guess that what
happened here was that you missed that
Nydia five shop when you play I don't
really miss it but I mean I think I
still have to go for it because I mean
g4 is my only ID right but you don't
have to play B there's no rush right or
is there a rush I don't know maybe
commit conditions h7 yeah yeah it feels
like you get to decide when you get to
play anymore right
okay well it's because well what did you
I mean I it's obviously very complicated
I suppose I have a yeah well oh I'm
sorry you weren't playing whew yeah I
mean you can play Queen e1 and talk to
93 here has a Turkish a chicken just
don't know what species I mean I
definitely have some sound conversation
for the pond right right yeah okay so
you saw this move by
I mean what was your sense here that it
was just a while I feel defined by joy
but I actually misses it looking for
then it's actually a bit difficult to
find a move he wants to take on g4 right
yeah I think it seems correct at least
made a very good practical decision
right because huh it takes everyone here
I think sir Knight f1 yeah look at 1tb
to change to lighter sweet takes check I
think you just draw Butchie for take
should be a bit officials a little right
right okay yeah so so yeah you know you
were just like I'm gonna close it down
yeah very nice and I guess this is the
best cities guy here what he does but
opens it but I think it still drawing
yeah yeah I thought it was an important
I'm basically going to play 96 I can
wear G Co team jersey but 96 is coming
anyway right so let's just state the
obvious that if rugby 63 yeah okay so
good so yes to do this and that's them
I bet he was hope I said he thought he
was better here I you know you at least
hope it leads over you're a little bit
better here
g3 I guess that's what it's got to do
and then this is now yeah I've never
watched exchange code
I thought he was gonna be a little bit
it was like a little bit close but yeah
it's not really close at all yeah and
breguet fruit de 5 was just a nice way
to finish it all yeah well all right
beautiful tournament yeah I felt like
you know you're so young that you
probably well you didn't grow up in the
Soviet times but this felt like you
played a Soviet tournament if you play
like the old school just keep it nice
and solid and take your chances when you
get it right yeah okay well
congratulations
um it's gotta be a huge victory and
hopefully we'll get you in the a group
next year all right that'll be nice yeah
all right congratulations again thank
you yeah all right well let's look in
okay Grigory why don't why you're here
let's get your opinion on this position
here this it seemed like our tourist was
just winning this thing and now it's
evolved what's this I don't know where's
the bishop go requested and okay why
does happen if you just do it but I
think it's just a door it should be
right because even a even if we have to
somehow sacrifice a rope for the pawn
which should be some way to come back
well what's the best way maybe it's not
so easy not so easy okay Rick f7 let's
try that first
Kim Chi for example
I'd say where I'll try this
yeah
maybe even rook g5 takes and come back
the g5 but they couldn't pray what
you're so into let's look at that first
thing rook g5 here here and you're
saying Brooke g7o wife is working in
yeah anyway so I'm a bikini aphorism
soft a rich wife I don't have
wait I have to admit I don't understand
so I'm thinking at for rookies five what
was the problem just separately would
you fight as there is a check on beat I
checked on be a very good okay yeah so
Kinney for gauge five yeah this is a if
you don't take college
King f3r yep
so we're assuming that rook h5 rook g7
is probably still a draw yep so king c6
to have me seven
wait can I take it now maybe a bit
sooner I think that might wait too but
okay that's not so be seven
well here I was thinking I could do
yeah but year here I think you love your
time here right yep here yeah it looks
like I'm at a time so no definitely so
maybe oh but you have dude haha yeah
let's go so this is our position on that
board
so rook f7 is one of our main candidate
moves
well I guess
it seems like rook f1 just loses
immediately to be seven basically czar
like to Moscow Lukas three than two
percent I don't see any point in making
such check that work f3 right just seems
like I'm healthy
yeah yeah okay so I guess we're saying
seven seems forced
so before I think I did King c-4 right
yeah
what about kindy for to prevent maybe
yeah what about King D for
maybe it doesn't make any difference I
still play not by the way I think you
just we don't need to be five all right
we can just move our king forward okay
so either King be our King see for King
f5 t g5 [ __ ] differently yeah and
then we're just gonna do this right yeah
I feel like sweet they'd be doing you
know our tours I you know it seems like
maybe he made it hard on himself but
maybe he's still winning in this
position actually it's funny when we
left this position it was I think it was
here and it seemed like before it seemed
like he was clearly winning and then all
of a sudden it got tricky here so let's
just see what he did he said here check
F 2 and then we get this position rook
g8 a beautiful move yeah
yeah I see she's best first impression
right right well you get that impression
because before he was just it seems like
I'm a piece and now all of a sudden we
have this yeah okay so unless Gordievsky
comes up with a defense that we don't
see it's totally lost
yeah I don't see any defense
and what Kinky's away to school is that
the look of a man who's winning he looks
oh yeah that was actually very
impressive because clearly he had lost
control of the game in this position
where he was thinking after route k4 but
then found
I'm gonna guess he found this whole
thing starting from this position here
b6 takes I don't know what else blacks
supposed to do
let's just try it one more time so okay
seven King c4 it doesn't it seems like
all this all the moves are the same
so you can play google was a page four
point right how do I go for each photo
well maybe so you're thinking oh go
behind okay let's try that so let's say
here here oh there there's an idea it's
good thing we came back good look maybe
not so anything so let's just show it it
looks like black actually has no
problems in this variation right I'm
guessing maybe maybe that's not true
actually
kimchi sui I guess King g3o king of C
King f3 seems right just the shoulder of
the King right H for food is going yeah
he's got it okay
oh man okay let's see if we can do
anything clever so actually maybe dis
important to play with g5 at some point
Rick f7 is on the board chemistry for
you well it doesn't make any difference
if I go king d4 right hip way it keeps
you for like okay let's imagine this
king e5
second off in this position
all right so again the problem is if
here here here we're worried about that
we're still worried about that yeah but
here which if I rough we're here works
if I work so so the king has to always
go to e4 put over B so II for but this
is cerritos home yeah but now the king
of least is one more yeah
all right let me let me just see if it
makes a difference so here King f3
fingers for you k-6
just for you now I take it just for you
well you got it - yeah I can just bus
just speaking seeks peace yeah or I go
like this ha ha ha ok so this is
happening
let's get the position on the board king
e5
so we're saying rook g5 is the attempt
at least it we're saying and then we're
saying the F for squares mind because
this is acquainting with check in the
following variation here here here visa
yep
oh man yeah and tubes your five results
aboard - no no g5 on the board oh man
our tours is playing AC came okay so
here it looks like there's really only
there's two choices going back I'm just
gonna go here and that's it so let's I
guess let's say that if let's just say
ephors the only attempt king b5
jeanny f3 but that's not gonna okay let
me just try this one more time
King f3 6
okay put can go he played King at four
now we're gonna see if we're cage five
is play it does seem important because
as we saw before if King e5 then black
is faster to get yeah but maybe he's
gonna take on the trap here maybe I can
still do it okay
okay but okay teenage three yeah he's
just be so I'm a Titan time yeah and
then always here oh so we're saying even
then even then then it's not complicated
we were making it way hard as we
predicted as we predicted okay but he
and black didn't try this King g3 thing
so to be clear the problem here was that
because the king was on here rook g7 rib
g5 and we clean with check so but this
looks at least we were thinking here
that rook g5 was winning but maybe
there's a trick
can I try this trick I Soter created
so once a king f3
dutiful
yeah but now you couldn't just take on
each one okay so let's go back for a
second so chief so we're waiting on this
move and we these guessing we're at g5
the players are they don't have forever
to move here and we just looked at rook
h7 to undermine the rook is there is
there another movie sighs rookie fine
like maybe no because I'm threatening
king g4 and Krypton cube she said on
Isabella
right so g5 age 7
okay so rook g8 didn't seem to work
because of this and on King a six we
just took
and the problem is now we can sack the
rook there were some positions we
couldn't sack the rook but just a given
yeah so g3g father actually go ahead I
thought maybe yeah maybe seven is a move
here
just a security mystery let's show that
so King a six teams of three King g3 b7
there you can take it now it now it's
simple yeah and then we're gonna that's
pretty easily drop it okay haha so
things have happened
let's look at what happened Heena for
rookies v g3 and now we're be fine okay
I'm just confused so it would be seven I
guess
[Music]
- yeah probably
wouldn't be one yeah but it's not what
could not work
I mean King g3 right yeah yeah trust and
I'm even threatening or a Kevlar yeah so
why would you do what he said yeah I
would G five now it doesn't feel great
that would be pretty fancy maybe though
let's give it a shot
I don't know if g2 is on the board I
don't know what else he's gonna do
besides were five right
and now I think if if King up you have
to worry about rook f5 but they were
lukkage 7 was it slightly excuse me
that's a check though
hmm is it all right let's so let's try
king b5 yeah
I mean the heads the same position is
one two three that's right right P five
gave away at them both all right so so
what let's just say here so it seems
like this was that our problem was if
Rick g5 we didn't see a win after really
upset and so he came up with Ricky five
but maybe he's just blundering this to
g2 or he has some idea that we don't see
yeah it was a boy
I haven't seen
Oh arts worse man yeah our tours
look it feels like he realized now yeah
he did something wrong
look at this position he had oh man oh
man okay jeetu
well I think you know he's up so many
points that in the turn of but it was
like really clinching it with this this
game is stupid I trust more real yeah me
Twitter question yeah of course it's
very difficult yeah are you friends with
Dmitry yeah yeah he said he's an
interesting player I would say
stylistically he's your opposite yeah
yeah yeah he likes the crazy
he doesn't even mind being worse okay so
Rick g5 West played and we were thinking
this is just a bad version of what we
had before
so King f3 we're anticipating
unfortunately white just doesn't seem to
have enough time king b5 rook over and I
don't even see a way how we could try to
even do these things right notice that
if h5 they do that no it's too close
yeah
so okay
and critics
it's not a bad way to make a door so the
idea is gonna be I guess that if the
King comes up then we check and then
this is gonna happen and if obviously if
white takes then this is just completely
a draw I'm tough to be someone because
you're busy okay nice difference yeah
you know it's funny too because actually
it all comes back down to this position
where all of a sudden Dimitri had played
but I thought well our doors found
definitely the way to at least get an
advantage because we you know you look
at this and you think what's gonna win
but then all of a sudden it's is you
know it's not so easy and I guess just
our final verdict was we we didn't ever
find a win for way I mean there might be
some are in there but it would be this
rook g8 looked like a very nice move but
we didn't find anything after work f7
oh yeah he's getting basically agreeing
to the draw right there with rook takes
g2
they're going to change everything yeah
alright grigory thank you so much for
staying to analyze that game I thought I
learned something that was a nice one
yeah very interesting
all right everybody I think we are gonna
wrap it up for today and you know we got
a lot of chests going on here of course
my day has just been full time watching
the Croatia thing which I'm just still
heartbroken that Bobby lost today but
watching that and then I yeah he lost
today after you have such a nice
position yeah and we're gonna get Kayla
back and he's going to give us a little
roundup of everything that's going on
everything going forward not only did
Bobby not win today
but Magnus surprisingly didn't win today
it looked like Magnus should have easily
won but I don't know he played some
moves that I thought were just natural
and we're gonna win and you know people
with the computer were saying that he
blew it but it wasn't obvious to me that
he was playing it when he blew it so
that's something typical going forward
alright yeah we see the players they're
talking about their game and with that I
think that's all the games finished for
today done so we did see a winner in the
B group to recap in grigory Oprah knew
you know so benevolently joined us there
to do some analysis on this last game
going on so congratulations to McGorry
as for tomorrow plenty to look out for
in the action in the C group night Sun
still has a very good chance to clinch
the championship only needing a draw but
in the a group it is anyone's tournament
there are two leaders
I believe with liam lee as well as let's
see here liam lee is actually the sole
leader in the a group yeah as we can see
going into this final round but he could
be caught by Geoffrey Zhang and Liam
Lee's opponent is Sam Shanklin so if Sam
wins his game he has a very good chance
to get into a playoff assuming Jeffrey
does not win in the C group let's take
another look at those standings just to
make sure we've got everything right
we've got our tourist Mike sounds
leading by a full point and Iran Coco
bein along with Dimitri Gordievsky both
trailing by one point
so if our turfs were to lose tomorrow
either Irama Cobian or dimitri
Gordievsky would have a chance to catch
him and force a playoff in the C group
so definitely a lot to look forward to
in coming round tomorrow remember our
show will be starting a little bit early
we're planning to start at 1:30 p.m. but
if the Croatia tournament runs a bit
long we will be starting 30 minutes
after the close of that broadcast my
name is Caleb Denby I was joined of
course by a grandmaster Jessie cry
giving you our thoughts on the games
today at the summer chess classic thank
you so much for joining us and viewing
and we'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you
you
you